yeah this is like actually kind of real
msg's magic it's truly magic and there's
all this idea that like it's like bad
for you or whatever but it's just not
that's like a lot of that's just fake
but um I did this like whole Deep dive
on MSG because I like to eat Doritos for
breakfast like who doesn't like Doritos
for breakfast a lot of people but I do
and what I learned is that the key
ingredient is MSG like Doritos are just
coated in MSG what it does is it tricks
your brain into thinking that you're
eating meat like some sort of like
protein Rich delicious thing which is
like our ancestors needed that to
survive and so we just love MSG and
that's how you're able to take
a chip like a Dorito which is just like
a refined corn paste that has been
smashed and then like fried and baked
and make it so delicious you just
sprinkle some of this magic powder on
there and you have a Dorito and I eat
Doritos for breakfast like all the time